plus à l'ouest à lviv on va retrouver
tout de suite gulliver craag notre
correspondant gulliver pas de nouvelles
frappes à lviv ce week-end mais les
réfugiés venant de marioupol eux
continuent à affluer
oui et ce matin j'ai parlé à
quelques-uns de fait déplacer un homme
qui m'a montré le trou dans le toit de
sa camionnette le résultat d'un éclat
mais il est tout de même réussi à sortir
de mario marioupol sain et sauf avec
huit autres personnes dans sa
camionnette il les a amenés en pologne
avant de revenir lui même en ukraine il
raconté à une route plein de dangers
qu'il n'y a pas eu de corridors
humanitaires proprement parler au moment
où lui et il s'est évacuée avec sa
famille et ses amis lui et d'autres
personnes à qui j'ai parlé aussi l'ont
confirmé m'ont dit que il y a des mines
des bombes non explosées sur la route
donc même si on ne tombe pas sur une
frappe russe on risque tout de même de
voir sa voiture
exploser à cause de cela ces personnes
m'ont dit qu'ils ont vu des voitures
brûlées le long de la route c'est pire
que dans un film d'horreur c'est la
manière dont mme l'a décrite cette route
de la sortie de marioupol l'une des
personnes qui s'étaient enfuis et ils
sont enfuis d'une situation seulement
parce qu'ils estimaient que cette
situation était encore plus risqué que
la route il vivait dans des sous sols il
n'avait pas d'eau très peu de nourriture
pas d'électricité
bien sûr et des bombardements constante
une famille qui était dans le sous sol
d'un immeuble mais qui monte à un
appartement dans ce même immeuble de
temps en temps pour se brosser les dents
pour se mettre un endroit un peu plus
confortable pendant des dd pause dans
les bombardements ont vu cette même
appartement frappé par un missile donc
ils se sont sentis très très fortunés de
ne pas avoir été dans l'appartement à ce
moment-là v mais vous imaginez la trauma
qui l'ont qu'ils ont vécu ils sont
sortis en exprimant aussi une haine
absolument profonde et ils ont souligné
cette femme en tout cas vraiment voulu
souligner que cette haine cette colère
ce n'était pas uniquement envers
vladimir poutine mais envers la russie
toute entière des habitants de marioupol
donc très éprouvé quel est leur état
d'esprit alors que l'ukraine on l'a vu
refusent de se rendre
ouais ils avaient des opinions un peu
mitigé sur l'attitude de l'ukraine et
est ce que les crânes avaient vraiment
la bonne stratégie parce que même si ces
personnes avaient une attitude très
patriotique et très proches craignaient
visiblement il disait l'ukraine n'est
pas vraiment en mesure de défendre les
civils à marioupol alors est-ce que le
coût en termes de vies humaines veut
vraiment vaut vraiment la défense de
cette ville c'était une question qu'il
se pose est sans vraiment avoir de
réponse mais ils m'ont dit que dans la
ville il y avait d'autres personnes qui
avaient avant cette invasion une
attitude un peu plus pro russe et qui
était selon ses hommes et femmes proches
craignent n 1 des victimes de la
propagande russe mais quoi qu'il en soit
qu'ils avaient une attitude un peu pro
russe et qui était beaucoup plus en
colère avec les ukrainiens avec la
manière dont la ville est défendu par
les combattants ukrainien et ils m'ont
dit qu'ils avaient bien peur que si
marioupol arriver à rester aux mains des
ukrainiens et que l'ukraine pour ainsi
dire gagner la guerre après il y avait
il y aurait beaucoup beaucoup de colère
et beaucoup d'insatisfactions parmi la
population de marioupol merci beaucoup
du livre craag en direct de vie valois